Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my full Marvel Hawkeye trailer video.
The larger one.
I did a reaction video yesterday.
So we'll go little bit deeper on the Easter
eggs also more about all the daredevil characters
that there including because love the series
does take place right next to hell's kitchen
where the daredevil characters are from some
of the other hidden Easter eggs they don't
completely reveal in this trailer.
There's a lot of big stuff happening in the
series.
But it's only six episodes.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the Easter eggs.
I will be doing videos for all the episodes
it starts in November obviously their trying
to convey this is a very Christmas based series.
Which is why they're waiting till November
to start releasing the episodes officially now
this is our second big marvel Christmas themed
project.
Even though it's a TV series, because Iron
Man three was kind of a Christmas based series
done by Shane black coincidentally Robert
Downey Junior was the reason why Shane black
did Iron Man three because they did kiss kiss
bang bang, which was also Christmas movie together
Like I said the whole tone the vibe of the
series is meant to be kind of MCU version
of diehard with that type of comedy like lethal
weapon is another Christmas themed action
movies they're going for something like that.
Just turning the beginning the footage.
So going through shot by shot.
So obviously there in the Chinese restaurant
a lot of you asked if this is the same Chinese
restaurant from the defenders that was called
the royal Dragon in that was in Hell's kitchen
in Hawkeye has taken his family to the Broadway
area to see the captain America Rogers musical
about Captain America's life.
Like a retelling of the captain America movies
through avengers endgame.
If you haven't been to New York City, or you
have been the Broadway this is a map you can
see it's right next to hell's kitchen.
I think just in general based on all the footage
in the trailer.
Like we have a lot of footage of them at 30
rock with the big Christmas tree.
There's a huge action set piece with the tracksuit
Mafia most of the series seems like it's gonna
take place between the east side and the west
side of Midtown in New York City.
Just this whole area of New York City right
across the middle.
That's also around where the king pin is the
kingpin himself doesn't live in Hell's kitchen
he lives in Midtown is also the area where
the avengers tower used to be, which is why
during the marvel Netflix series, especially
during daredevil you can see the avengers
tower in the background of the New York city
skyline.
So now makes a little more sense what people
are talking about Maia Lopez's echo being
associated with kingpin during the series
is a rumor about him having a small cameo
later in the episodes.
But the other biggest question the people
have asked year, especially in this opening
scene here when Lila Barton here his daughter
whose also called Hawkeye is talk about how
it's been so long since they've all been together
for Christmas yet.
There is one notable absence you not see his
wife Laura Barton played by Linda Cardellini
where is she even later in the trailer when
he packs them up in the Carson them homes.
They also worry, I'll be home for Christmas
you do not see his wife get into the car with
them socially right now probably what's going
on here is that she just stayed home.
Because he probably wouldn't send his children
home on their own to be by themselves around
the Christmas holiday for whatever reason
she probably just did not come with them to
see the captain America musical so I don't
of that are trying to say that she's dead
or anything like that because she was just
fine at the variant of avengers endgame.
The whole snapped everyone back she seemed
like she was totally normal when Hawkeye went
back to see them.
It just turning the timeline a little bit
because obviously Lila Barton who's Joe Russo's
daughter in real life you guys didn't know
Joe Russo put his daughter in the movie to
play Lila Barton during avengers endgame,
but because is that she been a couple years
and kids age up so fast.
She just looks way older now.
Originally I thought this was supposed to
be the Christmas right after avengers endgame,
but a lot of people said that there was a
leak from the set claiming this is a date
this says 2025 on it.
So this might be Christmas 2024.
It might actually a full year and 1/2 after
avengers endgame.
But they haven't confirmed that yet.
That will be one way of explaining why Lila
Barton here looks so much older than she did
during avengers endgame, you also remember
here, his youngest child Nathan Pietro Barton
is named after black widow and Quicksilver.
The reason why he's named Nathaniel and not
Natasha is because he's a boy.
So Nathaniel is just the masculine form up
Natasha that they use for him.
The reason why he named them Pietro is because
Quicksilver sacrificed himself to save Hawkeye's
life during Avengers: Age of Ultron that come
a lot of you have also asked what's going
on with Hawkeye's hearing aids.
So this is actually right out of the comics
Hawkeye wears hearing aids because he's slowly
going deaf during the series.
He suffered so many injuries and been around
so much combat across his life.
The just damages hearing so badly that he
needs hearing aids, also during the Hawkeye
comics one of the characters clown winds up
damaging his ear even more by stabbing him
literally in the ear.
So is not completely deaf but he's almost
stuff that's why he wears a hearing aids in
they just haven't really got into that, during
the avengers movies so far.
So they're just finally being a little bit
more comic book accurate for the Hawkeye series.
The character who does wind up stabbing him
in the air though is clown from that Matt
fraction Hawkeye run that they're using for
the basis of the story.
The Hawkeye volume for storyline.
Even though he doesn't appear in the trailer
the actor for free did reveal that he was
playing the clown character from the comics,
although based on reports from the said, it
sounds like you won't be wearing the full
clown makeup till towards the end of the series.
But if you're not familiar with the character
obviously he sounds and looks a lot like the
Joker he sort of like a parody of the Joker,
because that was just Matt fraction sense
of humor when he was writing the character
into this Hawkeye run he's basically meant
to be an upgrade villain hired by the tracksuit
Mafia to kill Hawkeye after Hawkeye spends
most of the run kicking their asses up and
down New York City he got a get that sense
from the trailer footage.
Like the tracksuit Mafia is featured heavily
from the beginning to the end of the trailer
and a bunch of different action scenes making
them seem like there the main villains, but
they're really not the main villains of the
series, there's are like mid bosses the Kate
Bishop starts out going after because it seems
like she's using the ronin costume to be a
vigilante going after the mob element because
her family has so many ties to the mob and
when Hawkeye confronts her, she just in the
middle of going after them.
So that's how Hawkeye gets involved with the
tracksuit Mafia, but in addition to all the
different footage of him fighting the tracksuit
Mafia all these funny moments like him throwing
them all talk cocktail right back at them,
you also the Maia Lopez echo character whose
being hired by someone different.
Like an totally other faction that's going
after Hawkeye as well in a separate faction
all the yelena belova black widow Val stuff
that's happening.
So there are at least three separate factions
that we know of in the series that all want
Hawkeye dead for one reason or another tracksuit
Mafia who hire the clown someone possibly
kingpin, or even Kate Bishop's mother hiring
Maia Lopez's echo character to kill him and
then whoever Val works for inside the US government
who's hiring yelena belova to kill Hawkeye
on the DL yet.
Remember, that Val works for somebody inside
the US government I've already explain my
theories about that.
I do think that she has ties to thunderbolt
Ross because it seems that she setting up
a thunderbolts team on the DL through all
the Disney plus series and the marvel movies,
or even a full-blown dark avengers team thunderbolt
Ross the world.
Authorities pretty much everybody knows what
Hawkeye did when he was running during that
five year time jump they were very aware of
him going around the world just murdering
all the different mob and criminal elements
is not meant to be a big secret or anything
like that, but he is fully retired.
Like according to the synopsis for the Hawkeye
series Hawkeye is a retired avenger the way
they explained during falcon and winter soldier
as part of the Sharon Carter power broker
storyline is that all the people who are like
Hawkeye did anything remotely shady during
the events of Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame during the five year time jump got
full pardons so Hawkeye was pardon for everything
that he did his ronin but you also the idea.
There's this reckoning like their still the
mob element the other people that survive
the people that got snapped inside as mob
families that he killed who then came back
after avengers endgame.
And now want him dead.
I've already talked about the captain America
Rogers musical obviously it's meant to be
this funny moment.
Just retelling the story of Captain America
and all the marvel movies through avengers
endgame of your big avatar the last air Bender
fan it sort of like the ember island players
episode where they retail the events of the
Avatar series.
But in a really cringy funny way.
So the funny thing here is that his family
is just laughing with Hawkeye at the events
of the avengers movies.
Because Hawkeye's told his family and his
daughter Lila all about his life as Hawkeye,
so they know all the stuff that he's done
the tagline timeless hero is just meant to
be a reference to him going into the ice for
all those years in then obviously the back
door reference to him in the time mission
during avengers endgame.
Returning all the infinity stones.
If you zoom and enhance on the caster a lot
of people have asked if Thor is being played
by Chris Evans stealth in real life.
Like if he's pretending to be the actor who's
playing the fake version of Thor.
Like doing a Matt Damon Loki situation without
more evidence from marvel all just say I don't
think that this is meant to be Chris Evans
I don't either trying to get that meadow with
this even though Chris Evans himself has done
theater then the whole idea here when he goes
out in the actually find Kate Bishop inside
the ronin costume.
Like who the hell are you only got your Hawkeye.
She such a Hawkeye fan girl if you look in
the background the truck here belongs to the
tracksuit Mafia so this is Kate Bishop going
after the tracksuit Mafia at the beginning
of the series Hawkeye getting caught up in
that in then it turning into a much bigger
thing in the later episodes.
The whole idea being that when they're picking
up in the series after avengers endgame after
year.
However long it's been is that they're changing
the Matt fraction Kate Bishop origin story
and just saying that Hawkeye rescued her from
the mob killing a bunch of mob people when
he was ronin during the five year time jump
in in the years since then she's been training
as an archer.
Like she just inspired by Hawkeye when she
gets rescued and becomes big Hawkeye fan girl
as she says oh my God you're Hawkeye in the
comics it was just a regular old avengers mission
But the reason why she targets all these mob
members when she's trying to become a version
of Hawkeye is because of her father and his
connection to the mob and because when Hawkeye
originally rescued her when she gets her origin
story she was being held hostage by the mob,
so she is this big vendetta against the mob
in New York City.
The other big chains are making to her origin
stories are doing things a little bit out of order
So she gets rescued by Hawkeye is ronin during
that five year time jump she's inspired become
a vigilante and tries to model herself after
Hawkeye.
Like they have the joke in the trailer where
she says some people are calling me the world's
deadliest archer and then Hawkeye sarcastically
says are you.
Some people like are you calling yourself
the world's deadliest archer, because clearly
she has a long way to go but in the comics,
when this storyline was happening.
She had already had a stint with the young
avengers and now it seems like as I said they're
changing the order of things, and she'll crossover
with young avengers at some point in the distant
future when they introduce all the rest those
characters we have a couple them like we have
Billy and Tommy from Wandavision and we have
Cassie laying stature who will see again during
Antman three quantumania.
So that almost got the full original young
avengers squad.
This is the apartment that they shared from
that Matt fraction run like Hawkeye has an
apartment inside the city that he uses when
he goes to New York City.
But this might be Kate Bishop's apartment
during the series.
This is also where they keep Lucky the pizza
dog who they rescue during one of their missions.
He gets into an accident and Hawkeye, winds
up rescuing him just because he takes pity on him
So that's why his eyes swollen shut.
The reason why he names him lucky is because
the dog almost died during the mission where
he rescues him.
The reason why the column Lucky the pizza
dog is just because they feed him a lot of
pizza which he enjoys mostly just about anything.
But you look is they're walking into the apartment
building here you see all the pizza boxes here
So this is another reference to Lucky the
pizza dog, he winds up staying with Kate Bishop
when Hawkeye goes back to his family and I
think you talking about the end of the series
like will yelena belova actually wind up killing
Hawkeye.
I actually do not think that that's going
to happen.
I don't think that they want to end things
on such a big downer like Hawkeye's talking
to Lila Barton his daughter here saying all
be home for Christmas.
I think that's the whole theme of the series.
Like he will barely just barely crawl home
in time for Christmas.
If you watch the diehard movies like that's
the whole idea, especially in diehard to like
he's trying to get home to his family for
Christmas but the flight is delayed because
of the villains.
But despite all the craziness of the movie
ultimately.
They imply he does make it home in time for
Christmas.
So I don't of the completely killing Hawkeye
off in the series.
But like I said the whole synopsis reads he
is a fully retired avenger and that's what
he's trying to he's trying to be retired in
just be a dad to his family who is missed
all these years with like they say it's been
so long since we've had Christmas together.
Remember, he's been trying to retire since
the events of Avengers: Age of Ultron and
circumstances have prevented him from doing
that.
Like sorry dude we got a giant purple space
grimace with a bunch of gemstones is gonna
wipe out half the universe.
This is Vera Farmiga she's playing Kate Bishop's
mother.
Like I said they might be changing the character
from the comics originally in the comics it
was her father that had ties to the mob.
Just because she such a huge actress you don't
cast someone like this to play a one off nothing character
She might be the one who has the ties to the
mob ties to the kingpin even ties to Val and
all the black widow stuff.
The post credit scene is happening.
I don't of he's gonna wind up being a version
of Mme. mask because it was a rumor that that
would be one of the characters in the series
Matt amassed just happens to be one of the
big Kate Bishop villains.
They also do remember there already so many
other characters and it's only gonna be six episodes long
That's why think a lot of people are saying
that supposedly this kingpin cameo is only
supposed to happen later in the series and
be very brief with him coming back in a much
bigger role during the Maya Lopez echo series
is far as I know, there isn't supposed to
be any kind of Matt Murdock or actual daredevil
showing up during the series.
But there was talk about daredevil himself
showing up during the Maya Lopez echo series.
I don't know when they can start filming that
but I think the gonna try and release it either
next year or in 2023 at some point.
The whole thing with echo is that she become
sort of a surrogate daughter to kingpin who
takes her under his wing is sort of molds
her into another assassin that he uses to
take out hits on people he uses her to go
after daredevil making her believe that daredevil
was responsible for the death of her parents.
So like I said during my last big Hawkeye
video she's not meant to be a villain she's
more of an antihero.
But she will be an antagonist trying to kill
Hawkeye.
During the events of the series one of the
many different people trying to kill Hawkeye
and yes this is a picture of Hawkeye in his
comic book costume.
Like the purple comic book costume are as
close as were getting to the classic comic
book costume with Maya Lopez to better look
at her character ever was asking if Val is
going to have a cameo scene during this if
she's going to recruit someone if she's going
to show up and recruit anybody at the end
of the series, it would be Maya Lopez echo
character in obviously.
I'm not expecting to see yelena belova show
up till the very end of the series where they
completely have it out and he tries to explain
what really happened with Natosha on vormir
like no I didn't kill her.
I tried to sacrifice myself but Natosha wouldn't
let me.
They haven't said the gonna do Hawkeye season
two or where Kate Bishop will show up after
this next I still think it's going to be a
while before we get our full-blown young avengers
project so it have to be something else that
she shows up in post all your theories in
the comments about which upcoming marvel movie,
you think that show show up in next but overall
it seems like it's can be really solid series
is starts November 24.
Like I said it's going to overlap with Amanda
Lorient book of Boba Fett episodes my full
marvel what if episode 6 video is get post
next on Wednesday just like normal is can
be the Kilmonger iron man episode.What if Kilmonger
saved Iron Man during the events of Iron Man
one make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my other big Hawkeye trailer
reaction video and click here for my
shang chi abomination video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!